uh representing the government this
morning is the university's minister
michelle donald hello to you thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning lots to talk about i want to
start with northern ireland though is it
a stalemate
um as a result it's hemorrhaging money
uh there's no working government what's
the british government going to do
our priority of course is to deal with
the the problem head-on we have a duty
uh towards the people of northern
ireland who are a fundamental part of
the uk as you point out the northern
ireland protocol is not working
and i i believe you know the the uh
concerns about that were reflected in
the recent result that we saw in the
election we're working at pace to
resolve this nothing's off the table
okay so what are you gonna do
well we are negotiating with the eu to
find a solution as we've said nothing is
off the table here if we need to
um we will through article 16 but we
want to try and negotiate as our first
priority scrapping the protocol
as i said that is that is on the table
as one of the options our first
um
attempt here is to try and negotiate
with the eu we want to resolve this at
pace we want a fundamentally a
functioning executive within northern
ireland for the people of northern
ireland that is simply not possible
unless we can resolve the issues around
the protocol so you are considering
scrapping the protocol
well well that's been government policy
uh for a while now we we've said very
openly nothing is off the table our
priority here is that the people of
northern ireland resolving this problem
getting a functioning executive up and
running
okay but um we hear from our island
correspondent of the 90 people just
elected to the assembly 54 of them are
in favor of the protocol in some form so
you'll be going against the will of
those that have just been elected
well as we know the dep have said that
they won't sit as part of the executive
unless the issues around the protocol
are resolved i said that i didn't say
that we were definitely doing that i
said it was on the table as a potential
option what are our go-to to begin with
is is to negotiate with the eu and try
and resolve this problem and find a
workable solution
yeah but as i've just made the point um
almost two-thirds of those that have
just been elected
uh want the protocol to remain in some
form
well yes that doesn't mean scrapping the
protocol finding a solution we are
negotiating with you to find a workable
solution that is our our primary
objective however should that not work
we would explore all options because our
goal here is to ensure we have a working
and functioning executive in in northern
ireland for the people of northern
ireland even if that was against the
will of those that have just been
elected
well as i've said multiple times here we
will not have a functioning executive
unless we can resolve this problem but i
think you know what we need to be doing
is negotiating trying to find a tangible
solution and then you know we can
discuss with you whether that solution
is is one that is popular or not what
does that tangible solution look like
well that that is what we're trying to
negotiate i can't outline the solution
at the moment because we are working at
pace with the eu to try and negotiate
that i mean it has been an issue for
some considerable time now as we have
seen so i'm guessing there are some uh
strides that have been made forward what
do they look like
well at the moment we have not made the
progress uh that we would like obviously
because otherwise the problem would be
resolved we've invested a great deal of
time and money into the northern ireland
protocol but it isn't working in the way
that we want it to
um for the people of northern ireland we
are negotiating we're working at pace
and we will be over the coming days
trying to rapidly find a solution
working with the eu
okay
if it's that urgent and you're
underlining that it is that urgent of
course we do have the queen's speech
tomorrow uh we could introdu you could
introduce a bill to override the
northern ireland protocol couldn't you
well look i'm not going to reveal what's
in uh the full queen speech tomorrow in
the green speech
are you ruling it out
i'm not going to uh reveal either way
what's in the the queen's speech um that
would break all protocol what i am
saying is that our first step here is to
try and negotiate with the eu and find a
solution okay
okay but i suppose the people of
northern ireland good people of northern
ireland who will be watching you this
morning will be looking for some
guidance on this stalemate that is
costing not only the british government
but also the people of northern ireland
they've not had a government
an assembly in place for some
considerable time it looks as though the
dup won't want to work with the
sinn fein who who won the most seats
over the weekend so they'll find
themselves in a position where
potentially they're going to have to
have enough another election again in
six months time it's an absolute mess
you've got the queen's speech tomorrow
you could take the opportunity to
introduce a new bill that would help out
the people of northern ireland
well i don't believe that the dup have
actually said that okay i believe the
dep have said that they wouldn't resume
their seats unless we resolve the issues
around the protocol which is what we are
going to do
yeah
that's what i just said
well no i i think what you actually said
is that the dep wouldn't work with
champagne that's not what they said they
said that uh we have to resolve the
issues around the protocol that's what
we're trying to do work at pace and sort
this problem out the people of northern
ireland i think we're in agreement here
okay we want to resolve this problem i'm
not sure we are um so just to be clear
you're saying that the dup would be will
your understand the british government's
understanding is that the dup would be
willing to work with sinn fein as long
as issues over the northern ireland
protocol were resolved are you sure
no i can't speak for the dup of course i
can't i'm a representative from the the
uh conservative government but what i
can say is that the their clear red line
that they have been very clear on is
that they will not resume their seats
unless we resolve the protocol so that
has to be our absolute priority
okay how long do you think it's going to
take before there's some sort of
resolution
i'm not going to put an
arbitrary figure of a number of days
that would be foolish i think on my
behalf but what i will say is that we're
working at pace you know we want to get
this done as quickly as possible we want
a functioning executive in northern
ireland and we understand the extreme
urgency of this
i thought this deal was oven ready what
happened
well yes it was the northern ireland
protocol is not working in the way that
we had uh intended it to do so and we've
been very open and frank about that one
okay but is it not the fault of the
british government you know we did a
deal we signed the deal we then said
actually it's not working quite as we'd
wanted to the european union came to the
table to change it in some form we found
out that we were going to have a border
down the irish sea even though the prime
minister said that was absolutely not
going to happen and if we were given all
sorts of bits of paper just rip them up
he said and throw them in the bin and
here we are
more than a year two years after 18
months after
when we were told we were having an oven
ready team everything was going to be
sorted the people of northern ireland
don't know from day to day how much it's
going to cost them to live
look the level of
bureaucracy that is being placed on
northern ireland's businesses is not
acceptable
well look the protocol is not working in
the way that we had intended it to do so
um and that is why we are trying to
negotiate and find a solution you know
there's no point rehashing uh where we
were a year ago the eu is obviously not
acting in the way that we thought they
would in terms of the northern ireland
protocol and we are now rapidly trying
to find a solution to this to resolve
the issue to their then get a
functioning executive in northern
ireland uh brandon lewis the secretary
of state for northern ireland in the
british government has gone over to is
going over to northern ireland today i
know that across government this is a
priority for us how do we feel about a
border referendum
well i think let's not um
uh
overcook this one as of of yet you know
even uh champagne said it would be sort
of five years off their priority in the
election my understanding is that they
campaigned primarily on issues like cost
of living not on uh a referendum and
over 50 percent uh of votes were
actually for uh for unionist parties or
parties that didn't want constitutional
change
yeah but they aren't in power and sinn
fein is so i put it to you again we
could be looking uh some way down the
track i'll give you that uh potentially
this prime minister if he wins the next
second term in office overseeing being
the guy that oversaw the breakup of the
union
i think that's a bit speculative and as
you say a long a long way down the track
in terms of a topic for conversation
this election does not indicate that
there is a groundswell or a dramatic
change in terms of uh wanting a split
from the union from the people of
northern ireland and the votes cast
demonstrate that in fact they
demonstrate a commitment to the union uh
which is at the heart of the work of my
government's policy and uh we will
continue with that and try and sort out
the issues around the protocol and
protect the united kingdom yeah you say
it's not a topic of conversation but i
was in dublin over the weekend and that
was the only thing they were talking
about
there are there will always be some
people that uh that want to progress
with this agenda what i i think i said
was that
the votes cast do not indicate that a
majority of people
now want to see the breakup of the
united kingdom from those living in
northern ireland
let's move to your brief head teachers
have said they're anticipating large
increases in their school energy bills
um adding that they've been forced to
cut
spending on teaching teaching assistance
and lesson time how are you going to
help them
um well we are increasing school budgets
by next year uh next academic year
school budgets will have gone up by
seven percent per people there are also
a package of support out there to help
them with things like energy and and
pooling resources
um but obviously we know that the global
fight against inflation the global cost
of living crisis is is is going to be
hard for everybody and that's why as a
government we put in place 22 billion
pounds worth of support we are
considering what else to do
and and we are continuing to work with
schools on not just this issue but many
issues
and you feel that the amount of money
that you've increased their budget for
but for next year this year next year is
going to be enough to cover
fuel costs
well of course we will continue to
monitor the situation but we have um
increased school budgets substantially
as i said but it would be up seven
percent per people and we'll continue to
monitor the situation and work with
schools to assist them through this and
through many other things you know in
the queen's speech as well we're also
launching a school's bill which focuses
on attendance and safeguarding and
standards and that is designed to ensure
that every child no matter where they're
born uh in england can have a fantastic
education and that's part of our
leveling up agenda okay just before i
let you go um beer with keir if he gets
fined should he step down
well that's a decision for for care
not for me
what my constituents are saying is um
that this this whole thing smacks of
sheer hypocrisy given the relentless
focus he has placed on what do you think
wrong party well i think this is a
decision for him he's going to have to
search his his soul after making this a
top priority over the last few months at
the expense of key issues like uh rising
cost of living etc but you know look
this is a this is a decision for him my
my takeaway is that it does smack of
sheer hypocrisy uh given because did you
mean to say take away then
well there you go yeah
there is good to see very quick
thanks very much for joining us thanks a
lot bye
bye